Carlos the Vietnam vet Marine who
volunteered for three tours and got shot
up in everyone in 1971 he was medically
retired because he had so much shrapnel
in his body that he was setting off
metal detectors for the next 42 years he
suffered from nightmares extreme anxiety
in public isolation depression yourself
medicated with alcohol he was married
and divorced three times
Carlos had a post-traumatic stress
disorder now I became a psychologist to
help mitigate human suffering and for
the past 10 years my target has been the
suffering caused by PTSD as experienced
by veterans like Carlos until recently
the science of PTSD just wasn't there
and so we didn't know what to do we put
some veterans on heavy drugs others we
hospitalized and gave generic group
therapy and other still we simply said
to them just go home and try to forget
about your experiences more recently
we've tried therapy dogs wilderness
retreats many things which may
temporarily relieve stress but which
don't actually eliminate PTSD symptoms
over the long term but things have
changed and I am here to tell you that
we can now eliminate PTSD not just
manage the symptoms and in huge numbers
of veterans because new scientific
research has been able to show
objectively repeatedly which treatments
actually get rid of symptoms which do
not now as it turns out the best
treatments for PTSD use many of the very
same training principles that the
military uses in preparing its trainees
for war now making war this is something
that we're good at we humans have been
making war since before we were even
fully human and since then we have gone
from using stone and sinew to developing
the most sophisticated and devastating
weapon systems imaginable and to enable
our warriors to use these weapons we
employ the most cutting-edge training
methods we are good
making war and we are good at training
our warriors to fight yet would we
consider the experience of the
modern-day combat veteran and we begin
to see that we have not been as good at
preparing them to come home why is that
well our ancestors lived immersed in
conflict and they fought right where
they lived
so until only very recently in our
evolutionary history there was hardly a
need to learn how to come home from war
because we never really did but
thankfully today most of humanity lives
in far more peaceful societies and when
there is conflict we especially in the
United States now have the technology to
put our warriors through advanced
training drop them into fight anywhere
on the globe and when they're done get
them back to peacetime suburbia but just
imagine for a moment what this must feel
like I have spoken with veterans who
told me that one day they're in a brutal
firefight in Afghanistan where they saw
carnage and death and just three days
later they found themselves toting a
nice chest to their kids soccer game
mindfuck is the most common term
it's the most common term I've heard to
describe that experience and that's
exactly what that is because while our
warrior spent countless hours training
for war we've only recently come to
understand that many require training on
how to return to civilian life now like
any training the best PTSD treatments
require repetition in the military we
don't simply hand trainees mark-19
automatic grenade launchers and say
here's a trigger here some ammo and good
luck
no we train them on the range and in
specific contexts over and over and over
until lifting their weapon and engaging
their target is so engrained into muscle
memory that it can be performed without
even thinking even under the most
stressful conditions you can imagine now
the same holds for training based
treatments the first of these treatments
is cognitive therapy and this is a kind
of mental recalibration when veterans
come home from war their way of mentally
framing the world is calibrated to an
immensely more dangerous environment so
when you try to overlay that mind frame
onto a peacetime environment you get
problems you began drowning and worries
about about dangers that aren't present
you begin not trusting family or friends
which is not to say that there are no
dangers in civilian life there are it's
just that the probability of
encountering them compared to combat is
astronomically lower so we never advise
veterans to turn off cost and completely
we do train them however to adjust
caution according to where they are if
you find yourself in a bad neighborhood
you turn it up out to dinner with family
you turn it way down we train veterans
to be fiercely rational to
systematically gauge the actual
statistical probability of encountering
say nied here in peacetime America with
enough practice those recalibrations
stick the next of these treatments is
exposure therapy and this is a kind of
field training and the fastest of the
proven effective treatments out there
you remember Carlos
this was the treatment that he chose and
so we started off by giving him
exercises for him challenging ones going
to a grocery store going to a shopping
mall going to a restaurant sitting with
his back to the door and critically
staying in these environments now at
first he was very anxious he wanted to
sit where he could scan the room where
he could plan escape routes where he
could get his hands on a on a makeshift
weapon and he wanted to leave but he
didn't he remembered his training in the
Marine Corps and he pushed through his
discomfort and every time he did this
his anxiety ratcheted down a little bit
and then a little bit more in a little
bit more until the end he had
effectively relearned how to sit in a
public space and just enjoy himself he
also listened to recordings of his
combat experiences over and over and
over
he listened until those memories no
longer generated any anxiety he
processed his memories so much that his
brain no longer needed to return to
those experiences in his sleep and when
I spoke with him a year after treatment
had finished he told me doc this is the
first time in 43 years that I haven't
had nightmares now this is different
than erasing a memory veterans will
always remember their traumatic
experiences but with enough practice
those memories are no longer as raw or
as painful as they once were they don't
feel emotionally like they like they
just happened yesterday and that is an
immensely better place to be but it's
often difficult and like any training it
may not work for everybody and there are
trust issues sometimes I'm asked if you
haven't been there doc how can you help
me which is understandable but at the
point of returning to civilian life you
do not require somebody who's been there
you don't require training for
operations on the battlefield
you require training on how to come home
now for the past ten years of my work I
have been exposed to detailed accounts
of the worst experiences that you can
imagine daily and it hasn't always been
easy there have been times where I have
just felt my heartbreak or that I've
absorbed too much but these training
based treatments work so well that
whatever this work takes out of me it
puts back even more because I see people
get better I see people's lives
transformed Carlos can now enjoy outings
with his grandchildren which is
something that he couldn't even do with
his own children and what's amazing to
me is that after 43 years of suffering
it only took him ten weeks of intense
training to get his life back and when I
spoke with them he told me I I know that
I can't get those years back but at
least now whatever days that I have left
on this earth I can live them in peace
and he also said I hope I hope that
these younger veterans don't wait to get
the help that they need and that's my
hope too because this life is short and
if you are fortunate enough to have
survived war or any kind of traumatic
experience you owe it to yourself to
live your life well and you shouldn't
wait to get the training that you need
to make that happen now the best way of
entering ending human suffering caused
by war is to never go to war but we are
just not there yet as a species until we
are the mental suffering that we create
in our sons and in our daughters when we
send them off to fight can be alleviated
but we must ensure that the science that
the energy level that the value that we
place on sending them off to war is that
very least mirrored and how well we
prepare the
to come back home to us this much we owe
them thank you